and Jerry Seinfeld has a new gig in NYC
he's doing a stand-up comedy residency
at New York's Beacon Theater but will
his three kids check him out they do
think that's funny but I don't I don't
do my set at home that's kind of a more
professional thing but I don't think
they're gonna come either maybe they
will I don't know I don't know what they
think of what I do I really do
Jerry wanted to do a once a month
engagement because he was inspired by
Billy Joel's residency at Madison Square
Garden you know a career kind of comes
out of the culture that you grew up in
and I feel like New York and Long Island
is kind of what gave me the perspective
to do what I do and I bought Billy
Joel's house about 15 years ago and I
thought well as long as I have his house
want one a nice steal his whole career
Amy Schumer recently performed at
Jerry's wife Jessica's baby buggy
charity and Jer offered Amy this career
advice don't ever do anything just for
the money do it because you love it if
you do something because you love it
it'll always end up being the right
decision no matter how it turns out
you